un
[Musique]
autre décembre un autre hiver à survivre
au froid en 2018
3149 itinérant avaient été dénombrés
dans la ville la pandémie en a jeté des
centaines d'autres à la rue
on estime un augmentation probablement
de 24 25 % dans le nombre de personnes
qui viennent à l'accueil bonneau
qui sont nous des nouvelles personnes
le centre de jour de l'accueil bonneau
qui est ouvert depuis cent
quarante-quatre ans n'a jamais accueilli
autant d'itinérance il vient ici pour
manger se réchauffer ou avoir quelques
vêtements les gens qui tombent
nouvellement en situation d'itinérance
c'est ce qu' ils ont perdu leur emploi
peut-être pendant la pandémie ils ont
perdu leur logement
parce que libé loyer coûte cher trop
cher ça représente quoi qu'on voit
endroits comme ici
ce 15 mai choteau pour moi tout les
joues françois de gens qu'on croise dans
la salle de repos n'a plus de toit
depuis février 2020 je trouve ça fait
beaucoup de monde qui se promènent d'un
jeu moi d'amener
fournir une aide quelqu'un
comme les sans abri sont plus nombreux
et que les mesures sanitaires empêche
les refuges de nuit d'être à pleine
capacité plusieurs sont contraints de
dormir au centre de jour de l'accueil
bonneau ce qu'on ne voyait pas avant il
met sa main terrine pour signer nuit à
me promener et puis
de pas dormi de la nuit de trois jours
sans dents mais
celui-ci
est en mairie si marshall pour quelques
unités de débordement ouverte 24 heures
sur 24 ont donc été inaugurée celle de
l'hôtel-dieu à 180 places ça moite de la
mission bon accueil la mise sur pied il
constate lui aussi une augmentation de
l'itinérance depuis la qu'ovide sept
jours en évolution mais ce qu'on voit
c'est peut-être une hausse de 600
personnes sur place ce qu'on rencontre
sont reconnaissants de pouvoir demeurer
à l'hôtel dieu les noix
le pôle est
tombée on dormait à terre on en met
partout
je frissonne actuellement nous dit
charles alors imaginez si je devais
dormir sur le trottoir m'aidera
d'ailleurs l'hiver dernier un innu de la
cour nord afin andré a été retrouvé mort
gelé dans une toilette chimique parce
que le refuge qu'il fréquentait était
fermée en raison d'une éclosion peu
après cette halte chaleur qui porte son
nom a été ouverte dans l'ouest du centre
ville
alexandra ambroise en est la
coordinatrice
lors de notre visite
elle et son équipe préparent et les
lieux pour une autre nuit une quinzaine
de matelas pour dormir et de la
nourriture qui sera servi jusqu'au matin
alexandra aussi constate à quel point
l'itinérance augmente notamment chez les
autochtones y arrivent à montréal pour
des services médicaux la cour puis après
sow sont comme panier s'ils sont démunis
six mois de février environ
on pouvait accueillir environ 20 25 30
personnes et
là présentement je peux accueillir entre
400 et 500 personnes par soir malgré la
nécessité de son installation obtenir un
financement reste compliquée pour
l'instant la halte chaleur à un budget
pour fonctionner jusqu'en février
j'aimerais ça qu'elle attende son je ne
dis pas qu'un casse aux lots pour
toujours mais castrés l'eau jusqu'à
temps qu'on trouve un endroit vraiment
stop sécuritaire aussi des haltes
chaleur par exemple sont importants sont
partis deux font partie de l'écosystème
mais à la fin est ce que c'est une
solution ou est ce que c'est un plaster
la vraie solution répétons dans le
milieu passe par plus de logements
sociaux donc chaque année on part une ma
chienne ça s'appelle les mesures
d'urgence hivernal ça coûte à l'état ça
coûte une fortune
c'est où est ce que je vais manger
aujourd'hui ou est-ce que je vais dormir
cette nuit mais ça ne règle rien en
attendant plus de 1400 lits sont
disponibles en urgence cet hiver c'est
plus que jamais on y viennent consignes
qu'il faut sortir des c'était logique
était hiver il faut pouvoir pérenniser
les ressources à moyen terme la nouvelle
responsable du dossier de l'itinérance à
la ville espère plus des d'ottawa et de
québec et elle a un plan sur quatre ans
on a promis 1200 m et unités pour les
personnes en situation d'itinérance dont
une partie pour les personnes
autochtones ainsi qu'on a promis doubler
les blogs dédiés à l'itinérance qui va
passer de 3 millions par année à six
millions par année plus d'argent pour
venir en aide à françois et chantal
ceux-ci se poser ya tellement de choses
qu'il faut ou encore dry il ya la teigne
psychologique il faisait
ce soir là chantal lé signe un bail dans
le nord de la ville the strange d'un
dieu merci merci merci mon dieu merci et
bonne chance aux autres c'est du
réchauffé
[Musique]